welcome everyone to the Android
developer lab at this is the the first
episode of the Android developer lab
plus and we're really excited to be to
be launching it so this is a revamp of
what we used to have called office hours
and it just basically expands on that
show so let me start off by introducing
the team of the first year hi guys are
monitored the diwani and I'm based out
of Hyderabad office in India um i'm tony
chen and i am based out of Hong Kong and
I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm based out of
Sydney Australia so we're really really
glad to have everyone joining us today
we are just getting the show started so
just give us a few minutes we are just
making sure that people online are able
to join our our link and as soon as
we've got that up we should be right to
go so in the meanwhile um Tony do you
want to give us an update on some of the
questions that we had last week to be
with the lower level media oh yes sure
so let me let me pull a question up so
basically there are there are two
questions are we we got with left an
answer last last week and so we try to
find an answer and there you go so the
first one is um Kendall deep deep stage
fright classes be used in the jni code
somehow um J&I person enjoy source tree
incompatibility and stable lated
interface so um so basically the answer
is oh yeah why not and and you can
certainly do that but but one thing you
need to pay attention is a form for if
you're using the native interface is
there's no guarantee are those in
phase our will not change so when you
when you when you when you go for that
approach make sure you pay attention to
our source three changes and make sure
it's not broken so so that's the caveat
so another question we laughin answer
last week was is there any supportive
way to stream live video and audio so I
think last week we forgot to mention
something that we do have HTTP live
stream support in honeycomb honeycomb
and plus devices so um also be 4 pi 0 to
a honeycomb there are the awesome
probably commercial solution as well for
for life screaming and now and we have
seen developer done that we can they're
all solution before in on our end before
so it's pretty doable so I guess that's
um pretty much a straight address by
some of them another question last week
thanks Tony so what we're going to do
today is a little bit different that as
I mentioned that the format is changing
so let's get started we are going to
flick over to our presentation right now
and here we go so uh Leslie we just
start off with some news these are just
basically some of the events that have
happened in terms of and the Android
developer world over the last week the
first one is that we've launched preview
two of the Android developer tools
version 21 so this is the upcoming
version don't be too concerned if the if
you're able to get the URL down or not
we will go and edit the YouTube video
and put it in there but certainly you
can do a google search for this the next
one is that we one of the our team
members have has put in the has released
some sample code actually for some
scrolling trick so let me just bring
that up
so the ADT preview is is up torn or bite
torn or by is one of the engineers that
works on the SDK tools and he's
announced the availability of these
tools on his Plus page Roman Nurik and
Nick butcher who are also Android
developer advocates put together this
great little sample app there's some
code there and you can just see what
what it basically looks like you'll
notice that there are some scrolling
tricks that we've been implementing with
our apps so as they scroll down here
you'll notice that that the little white
bar disappears but as soon as they pull
down the white bar shows up again so
it's kind of like a floating or dock bar
across the top but there's a sticky
version of it as well so it's a it's
some really nice source code there so
you can see if it's worth implementing
or something that you consider to be
useful for your apps we use it in the
Google Play client actually another one
is that is what we call the pin or
progress so it's something that that we
sort of introduced in the Google movies
client and you'll notice that as your
and as well as books actually so as
you're downloading content you get this
little pin which is what you toggle to
say whether to download or not and the
progress bar starts to fill up so Roman
again put together some some great
sample code and you can you can go and
grab it from the URL that's just
displayed here as well it's just a
shortened version but you can just
follow Roman on google+ so with that
being said that's pretty much the
biggest things that have happened from
from our side of the Android developer
ecosystem I know there's been plenty of
things in the community side ah the
other thing we're going to do today
that's that's a bit different is that
we're going to have a message from our
sponsor and our sponsor this week is the
Android manifest file so we thought we'd
share some pro tips with you guys and
because there has been some confusion in
the past and ways to really optimize
your
your development so we thought we'd
share those with you we're going to
start off by talking about users SDK so
users SDK is a tag that you'd have in
your manifest file and there's a couple
of attributes on there that are quite
important and they can really make some
some dramatic impacts to your to your
apps compatibility and availability on
Google Play so let's let's get started
the first one is the minimum SDK version
or we stated as min SDK version so what
it is is it it basically tells the
device that hate that this app needs a
minimum version of this API level to be
able to run now when you specify the
minimum SDK version in your manifest
file it is up to you as the developer to
ensure that you're not calling api's
that are not supported in that SDK
version or if you are you're putting
version gates around them so you are
checking that that particular API is
available on that version of the
platform now the good thing is that once
you start using the SDK version if
you're using more recent version of the
Android developer tools we added Lynch
support so lint is a compile-time check
the guys and sees if you're doing
anything anything not quite right with
your source code so this is an example
where what it'll do is it'll actually
check what the minimum SDK version that
has been specified in your manifest is
and to see whether you're calling any
particular API is that are not supported
in that minimum SDK version so it's a
really nice handy tool and those
warnings should definitely be actioned
the thing about the minimum SDK version
is that when a user goes to install an
APK so let's say your side loading a nap
the operating system will actually check
whether it is a version that's higher
than the or higher greater than or equal
to the minimum SDK version so the
operating system itself will confirm
that Google Play also does this so if
there's if you're running on let's say a
gingerbread device and a minimum SDK has
been
set to Honeycomb if you search for that
app on google play on your gingerbread
device play won't actually show that
that app actually if you go to the web
version of google play and you sign in
you you search for that particular app
you'll notice that when you try to
install the app through the web version
there's a way you can choose which
device you want to install to it won't
actually present devices that are below
that minimum SDK version so by default
the the value that's there it's an
implicit value that defaults to one
which means it supports every version of
Android but we always in terms of best
practices we recommend that you
explicitly specify the minimum SDK
version and it's also a way for you to
make sure that you're targeting the
rights that abuses if you have a very
media heavy app for example or an app
that you know requires a certain level
of device minimum SDK is one way to do
it one way to check to ensure that it
doesn't get installed on the wrong
device so please you know go and
explicitly specify minimum SDK you might
be looking at that in saying well it's
not there by default so why do I need it
well the next bit of useful information
is the target SDK the target SDK is is
basically saying to about you're saying
by specifying a target SDK that this
particular app is guaranteed to run on a
particular API level and the reason that
you should be should be stating it is
that it actually enables a whole bunch
of features in the background so what we
recommend and we're going to talk about
what some of those features are what we
recommend in terms of our best practices
is that you should always set your
target SDK version in your app to be the
latest version of Android okay just
because you said it to let's say 15 api
api level 15 if you try to install them
on let's say a gingerbread device which
is api level 9 it's not going to
actually prevent it from running what it
will do is that it will default back to
the API level 9 behavior on those API
level 9
devices and this is where minimum SDK
helps because what you do is you use the
minimum SDK to specify what's the lowest
version or oldest version of Android
that you can run and you use target SDK
to specify the one that you're really
targeting now remember earlier I said
that there will be some features that it
enables so let's talk about some of
those if you target API level 11 or
greater you actually get some nice
benefits it enables the holo theme for
example in your app so that your all of
your UI controls look modern look up to
date they don't look like the
gingerbread versions so for those apps
that you've seen occasionally running on
your ice cream sandwich devices that
seem to have gingerbread looking buttons
it's because they haven't specified a
target SDK version of 11 or higher so
it's really important that you do go and
enable it so you get the holo theme then
there's a screen compatibility mode
which is all about saying whether you
want your app to stretch to fit or zoom
to fit and the more interesting one now
is obviously the legacy menu button so
without with our current generation of
devices like the Galaxy Nexus or in fact
most of the Android tablets they don't
have a physical menu button if you try
to run in a legacy app and older app
with a on your on these newer devices
what you'll find is that in your
navigation bar you get a little menu
button it looks like the overflow button
but it's the menu button that's the
legacy menu button and it's something
that really you should be moving away
from and moving towards using the action
bar so target SDK version is what you
use as soon as you specify 11 or greater
it'll it'll enable these things on the
newer versions of the platform if you
target 14 or higher you'll automatically
get hardware acceleration unless you
explicitly mentioned that you don't want
hardware acceleration in your app but
there are very few scenarios that that
we found where you wouldn't want that
hardware acceleration so really you know
try and follow these best practices of
keeping the target SDK version up to the
maximum version now you might be asking
yourself well if this is how it works
why doesn't it implicitly
target the newest version all the time
the reason is because there can be
changes in behavior so when we make
certain changes in behavior to the
android framework we we make sure that
we keep the existing behavior for if the
app is targeting all the API levels so
an example of changes in behavior is
that we change the async cast threading
model in API 13 where instead of having
a pool of threads that that executes
async task we use a single thread that
runs async task serially but still in a
separate thread so there can be minor
changes in behavior and so that's why we
recommend that you do not only do you
update to the latest API level in your
target SDK version but you do go through
your full test cycle but as I said the
benefits are great yeah one thing i want
to add this also like for example the
action bar when you enable a set target
SDK to greater than y 11 so action Bob
will be something will be enabled like
at that point so when so if your app
hasn't been tasked on the later version
so make sure you test your app as well
because that made them in that will have
an impact on the UI of your application
yeah thanks Tony so the last one is the
max SDK version and actually as of
android 2.0 point one the operating
system doesn't even look at the max SDK
version it's only used in Google Play so
what happens is if you specify max SDK
version it means that Google Play won't
often devices that are running newer
versions of the APAP sorry newer version
of the API it won't offer your app this
particular app to those devices so
you're kind of saying hey it'll only run
up to ice cream sandwich and not not any
further than that and really as an
Android app developer what you want to
be doing is maximizing the the number of
people well maximizing the number of
people that can install your app right
so you don't want to be specifying these
max SDK versions because remember what i
said when you're using target
sdk version and you're fixing it to a
particular value we will can we will
ensure that you get this same behavior
so that async task change that I
mentioned before if your target SDK
version isn't 13 or greater you will get
the older behavior so in general we
don't actually recommend you use max SDK
version and the only real situation that
that we've that that I can come up with
where you might want to use it if you're
using multi APK support so in play
you're kind of saying well I've got
different apks targeting different
versions of the platform so an example
of what you might want to do that is
where you have an appt today that's
supporting a set of older android
versions but in your next version of
that app you kind of want to say I'm no
longer supporting those old devices or
old API versions but I don't want to
take that old version off the store for
people that have all devices so then
what will happen by using this you would
specify max SDK version for your older
version of the app and then people with
all the versions of the API so you need
a combination of Max and min obviously
use people with the older versions of
the platform will get the older app so
people on 1.5 1.6 and then your newer
users can get the latest updates and
latest features so it's really about
making your life easier but it is
something that that developers can
overlook from time to time and and we
really recommend that you you certainly
use minimum and target SDK versions yeah
I think another thing i want to add is
another use case i saw developer using
the max SDK version is when when there
is a major release enjoys release
something fell from a just temporarily
set the mat mass SDK awarded doing I
extensive extensive testing on the under
on the major release I think that Pablo
another will use case that may be useful
for temporary setting the mass as SDK to
to the
yeah alright so that's users SDK the
next one we'd like to talk about is
users feature so you know often you may
have an app that you're you know you're
using some sort of hardware feature but
it's not critical to the operation of
your app so an example of that is that
you may have a brilliant app that does
great photo editing now one of the
features of your app might be that you
use a you that you allow the user to
take photos as well as edit existing
photos in the gallery now if you're
taking photos you might be wanting to
use features like autofocus so you don't
want to get into a situation where
people that have devices that don't have
a specific hardware feature unable to
use the core functionality of your app
so there are ways that you can actually
specify that hey I would like to use
this hardware feature if it's there but
if it's not then go ahead anyway and
what that's what we're going to talk
about now so in terms of how you would
do this you would typically say hey I
want to use a camera and then you can
make decisions on which of those
features are optional so in the example
here we're saying we're using the camera
we're also using auto focus but you'll
notice at the bottom of that white text
it says android required equals false
and that's stating that this particular
auto focus feature is optional now keep
in mind that when you request these
users features for anything that is said
to be required equals true Google Play
will feature will filter on those so at
the top that we said users feature
camera we didn't actually specify
required it's implicit its implied there
that required is true that's the default
value so the second part the autofocus
is actually saying it's optional so you
can make a decision as to which part of
which of these features are optional in
your app and then at runtime what you do
is that you can go through the package
manager to go and find out if the system
has that particular feature so here
we're checking if we have the feature at
runtime and then conditionally we are
executing our code so this is
a nice way to kind of you know broaden
the the number of users a number of
devices that your app can run on whilst
making sure that your you know your app
still hangs together now I've provided a
URL there at the bottom we actually had
a blog post about this I'll just bring
that up we had a blog post about this in
all the way back in October actually in
october two thousand ten rather i should
add so it's it's worth your while to
have a look at this code and have a look
through this blog post that you know
kind of walks it walks you through it in
more detail so let's uh let's go to the
next section of the presentation users
permission so obviously developers know
that you can add install time you
specify which android permissions you'd
like but what we found is that there are
a number of apps that request
permissions that are over and above what
they really require and users are
starting to really object to this their
android users are quite tech savvy and
they they tend to know when you know an
app is requesting more than they need to
like a wallpaper app should never need
to you know read through my contacts for
example so what we wanted to do was
present you a list of what we consider
to be the worst permissions that that
apps request there there are
circumstances where you might need some
of these permissions but you really need
to think long and hard so the first one
well we're going to start from ten and
go backwards so changing Wi-Fi settings
there are very few instances where you
should need to change it uses Wi-Fi
settings doing things on boot you know
again it's one of those things that on
boot you don't want a whole bunch of
apps starting to do a lot of things so
keep that in mind you know start your
app at the right time don't put an
unnecessarily load on the app on the
device by having your app start up at
boot and you know stay resident
continuously you don't need to know what
other tasks are running on a device in
most situations that
again very few scenarios where you would
need to know this obtaining a fine
location now there are some apps that
actually do need a very specific
location but often that you'll find the
course location will be good enough or
the network location you can also
register for location updates that that
other apps request so try and be a
smarter about retrieving this location
getting fine location obviously also
triggers the the GPS and you know the
GPS in these mobile devices do consume a
lot of power so really challenge
yourself to or ask yourself do you
really need it you should never need to
read the system log and it's something
in jelly bean that's actually going away
you'll be able to read your own logs but
you won't have you know this permission
will pretty much not do anything from
jelly bean onwards you certainly won't
be able to see the log of the rest of
the system so number five you should
never need to directly call phone
numbers we actually have an intent that
you can fire to say hey go fire up the
dialer and you know pre populate it with
this phone number the user still has to
click dial and that's the right way to
do it rather than directly call a number
yourself through your app fire up the
intent the intent doesn't even require
you to have a permission to do it as I
mentioned with things like wallpaper
apps asking for reading contacts and
calendar people are very conscious about
their privacy these days so you know
again ask yourself do you really need
that capability the same goes with
bookmarks displaying system level alerts
you know spamming the notification bar
for example and you know in general
system level alert permissions and
number one and the this is the worst one
is for apps to be sending and receiving
SMS ins you know there are some premium
services that may do this but the
majority of the apps that we see that
are requesting these kind of permissions
certainly don't need to do it I'm not
saying that they all have a malicious
intent but you should you should really
be careful about this one because you'll
notice that many of the apps that
request these sorts of permission get
very negative feedback in the Play Store
so and once it's there it's you can't
get rid of that negative feedback so
what should you do if you need some of
these permissions firstly describe the
reason that you would need the
permission on the Play Store you have a
great big section of description and in
there you know you should state hey we
are we need this permission because this
is how we're using it that's the
responsible thing to do users love
transparency so the more transparent you
are with them the the more they're going
to trust you as well to do the right
thing and you know that there can be
ways of architecting your app such that
you can separate that bit of
functionality and make it optional
through maybe a like a plug-in or an
add-on for your app that uses cousin can
install separately and then you can try
triggering it through that mechanism and
finally just put yourself in the in the
shoes of the user would you be
comfortable giving other apps the
permissions that your app is requesting
if you truly believe that the answer is
yes then go ahead and do some of these
things but make sure again transparency
and you want to gain the trust of the
user and you certainly don't want to
abuse it okay so that's a that's the
concludes the sort of short presentation
that we've had on the Android manifest
pro tips from for now what we're going
to do is move to the Q&A section and of
course this is going to be questions
related to Android development and you
know we have the moderator questions we
we also have some people that are that
are here live with us so let's open it
up for questions let's see if the live
audience has anything hey Andrew Hey and
just a quick one on the stuff you're
talking about just a moment ago with the
missions is it likely that or an
alternative that you'd be able to have
required kind of true or false on
permissions in the same way that you can
with features so you know if I can have
location in fine location as a
permission it's not actually required
and I could then test for that in my app
to say okay
these five features of my can be used
quite happily but if I've been given
permission to query the location and
this extra feature you know like
pinpointing your location on map will
then become usable I mean at the moment
a user has to accept all of the
permissions in one fell swoop swoop
rather than individually choosing which
ones I've got access to jagged then
query later on so that's a good question
in so let me start off by saying it's
very hard for us to comment on what
direction we are going but but let's
let's just talk through some of that
part of it is that we want to ensure
that users have a have a really good
experience when they install apps
they're not presented with you know a
ton of questions that say you know
here's for permissions that are
requesting which ones you want to turn
on and off so we really need to think
about the user experience when it comes
to installing apps and then we also need
to think about well what about
developers that are already got an
existing set of apps then are not
stating that those permissions are
optional should users be able to turn
off permissions on a nap so what does it
mean for our existing set of apps what
does it mean for the user experience if
we were to do this so there are a couple
of things that play here and so I as I
said I can't really comment on what's
going to happen in the future but yeah I
guess I guess one of the current
implementation developer currently is
doing slice is to build some plugins
right and and in those plucking asking
for those optional permissions right I
mean if you have something that you
think your apps can be optional you can
put those features into a into a
separate 14 so and Wall Street least a
plug-in him in a separate PK file is
going to be hosted on the google play
store yeah so it's a separate app
totally separate app you what you would
do is you could you could go and check
if you know that's installed and if it's
not installed you could say so when you
user tries to use a feature you could
say hey you actually need to grab this
piece of functionality from the place
too and you could direct them to the
place to order you know page so they
need to search for eternity and Impala
see why that's okay because it is really
are offering different functionality is
not like you're putting like multiple
the same ever
asian on on the place all which is what
we discourage yeah going back to anchors
point just a moment ago I mean all
you've done there is kind of change the
page can I use your permission dialogue
into a hey please go to the google play
store and download the map plugin for
your application you've not kind of made
it as seamless and there's still a user
interaction there yeah it is a delicate
balance there's no doubt about it it's
how it's not a simple problem we
certainly admit that um yeah yeah okay
all right so we've got a couple of other
people on the on the on the Hangout it
any other questions from from anyone
before we move to moderator okay so
let's move to the moderator link when
you just bring that up and i will screen
share actually just do that window
because then it will be nice and nice
and large there we are so Tony doing a
walk us through these or on your word
yeah anyway you want to take it all okay
uh I'm sorry good question i'll be
talking about okay I'll take this one so
why do developer android developer guys
for parsing xml recommend using the xml
parser when it appears the sets
processors are an order of magnitude
faster um so i think one reason we are
recommending the tub the pool parson
actually sets paws are in general is in
performance why compared to like Tom
process is is really better and in in
most cases like the pool parser
performances is actually better arm but
from the article you you propose there
the pool parlor is the sax parser that
to implementation the sets one is really
have a better performance but against it
actually depends on the benchmark and we
can take this as a feedback and and and
and bring this back to the engineering
team and see whether there is there's
really a performance optimization there
we can do on the pool passer also in
terms of coding style i think the pool
part is better because you can select
even you you want to listen to what our
verses like the sax parser you have to
is kind of like a push model instead of
a pull model um so that's that's why i
have anyway having anything to add or
anchor uh yeah i mean with the one
differences with posture when you listen
to the event types starting and you can
only look at the events that you are
interested in but with with the sax
parser you would go you'll have to go
through all the other ones that come to
the code that you write so that's one
benefit of using a pull parser okay yeah
thank you so that the next questions
actually from Andrew Andrew says I'm
using an HTML image map for each area
that is clicked by a blue rectangle it
can be orange depending on the device
it's it's displayed briefly even if the
shape happens to be a circle can this be
turned off and he's tried a few WebKit
tricks in the CSS but didn't have much
luck now i'm andrew i actually had a
look at this and it seems like the the
implementation that we have in the in
webview unfortunately has this this side
effect there is a nothing we can do at
the moment unfortunately we can we can
pass it on to the engineering team one
thing I can tell you however which it
doesn't really help you i think if this
is an app it doesn't help you but if you
have some website I to nap okay if it
was a website what I did is I try
in chrome on Android and it didn't
result in those squares episode I'll
inform yeah yeah so I think this is a
it's a difference in behavior on the the
webview component on Android I even
confirmed it actually in the browser
itself not just the web new component so
yeah we'll take that back and report it
to the team but is it is it a major
showstopper for you oh it's not it's
just something that the client i'm
working with his notice to every time
they use the image map and they're
clicking around on the page they see
these little blue squares appearing and
he's just a little bit annoying compared
to when you use these sites on the
desktop or on an ipad you don't see
these kind of highlighted areas as
you're clicking around on the site so it
was just something i was going to work
out if there was a bit of CSS that I
could stick in there or whether there
was an attribute in the XML I could put
around the the webview that would turn
that kind of stuff off but yeah I've
tried to several things and none of them
seem to work so yeah sorry about that
yeah we'll take it back to the team go
on and let you know all right next
question and why is there no satellite
mode from that view the method set
satellite actually sets hybrid mode
including both tiles of aerial imagery
with roads and named superimpose so
right now there is no way to show only
aerial imagery without roads annually
yeah this is true and we have an open
issue on Android issue tracker regarding
this is something you look at thanks for
your feedback yeah all right again
thanks for reporting it sorry we don't
actually have a workaround for you the
only workaround which I probably
wouldn't recommend when it comes to
using that the map side of it is you
know using the using the web version of
the map and the only reason i say i
wouldn't recommend it is just because i
find that you know using that that
JavaScript version of of maps in a
webview it doesn't perform as well as
the native map view or sorry map
activity
so yeah next why are we not able to
attach image in the male body now this
person this doesn't sound like a
developer question actually um so don't
know the answer here's another one that
doesn't sound like a developer question
why does android not have an official
google sites app i would love to
customize my websites on the go um i
suspect you could probably just go to
the google sites page in your Android
web browser and modify it there I don't
know that there would be a massive
market for people changing the modifying
their Google Sites through a mobile app
anyway that that's not necessarily the
official reason but that's just my
thought so not a developer question
we'll move on last time you mentioned
that there are some new notification
support in the support library can you
tell us what notification features have
been added there can android 4.1 like
notifications work in earlier versions I
knew it uh yes we've had it a rich
notification support and there are some
release notes with the support library
which you can look at the new features
added but we do provide not rich
notification support like the jelly bean
with ICS version yeah all the other big
content are expanded layout and the
priority those things are now supporting
the content notifications of that cool
um all right well there are no more
questions on the moderator are there any
other questions from people that are on
the Hangout nope look like it well um
and on in that case well thank you for
joining us for our our first episode of
Android developer lab plus we'll be back
again next week as you notice today we
did we did a presentation on the Android
manifest file will be doing more of
these sorts of topics of the
week and so we've got a few ideas in
mind but if there are some specific
topics that you guys would like us to
talk about please let us know you know
we're always interested in your feedback
and we do take it seriously so on that
note thanks for joining in and see you
next time see you next week okay I